foreign
CBS deals this morning we have a deal
for those looking for that special gift
whether for a loved one or yourself and
all that exclusive low prices
to start shopping now scan the QR code
on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner joins us with more Beth good
morning good morning thank you for
having me and yes cbsdeals.com shop with
us as we go I'm ready to share with you
something very emotional and awesome my
husband just had his birthday and I
created an heirloom video book for him
so this actually on the cover I was able
to select is a picture of my beautiful
family with all my kiddos but when you
open up the heirloom video book a video
begins to play so the way this works is
you purchase the book they send you a
link then you upload photos from your
phone your tablet your computer or video
and sound so you can actually have full
videos on here your kids playing soccer
maybe you're proposing to somebody and
that's my husband actually there opening
this up when we gave it to him for his
birthday so use this link either now or
save it for later it never expires you
go on that link you're going to upload
of those photos I think Mother's Day
Father's Day showers graduations
retirement holidays birthdays you name
it this is literally the perfect gift
said your hubby got a little emotional
he did he teared up a little bit I don't
know if I'm supposed to tell everyone
that but I love you Alex happy birthday
so this is wonderful definitely a great
gift and right now 25 off so starting at
36.75
cherished moments to give now nothing is
complete for a lady without her bag of
course and this is Lulu Dharma amazing
line the woman that invented this
actually was over in Europe studying in
Paris and London learning about fashion
and decided she was going to create a
line of bags that are not only gorgeous
but also eco-friendly they're vegan this
is vegan hand woven soft you gotta touch
that nice soft this is the everyday bag
you can wear it on your shoulder you can
crossbody it plenty of room for
everything that you need to carry love
this but I also love the Weekender now
these are his and hers so I'm going to
give you the his okay here's your his
here's my letters okay yes the
houndstooth you can just throw it over
these are big bags like from the first
episode of succession that's it that's
it now you've got your Weekender look on
look how nice that houndstooth is you
know in the South they love their
houndstooth but all of it even the
inside made from recycled plastic
bottles all of the materials recycled
beautiful gorgeous they hold everything
could I carry this can I can could I
carry this off or not I feel like you do
let's see give it a spin give it a
little spin it it spins like a full
bottle spin I love it I think it's
perfect his and hers that is the look
right there so these are beautiful they
start off at
49.99 they're 49 off so grab these These
are great by the way college kids my
kids they live using these because they
go everywhere all right so I'm gonna hop
in here this is the calming heat sauna
wrap what sweet sitting and you're
sitting a heat a sauna wrap a sauna wrap
so maybe you don't have a gym or a spa
that you go to they're too expensive
whatever you can bring the sauna home to
your house inside here I've got infrared
heat that's warming my body giving me
all the benefits of a real sauna I've
got the remote so I can control not only
the heat but also targeted vibration
massage there's a pillow you can move
that around for your back your neck and
think about it for hundreds of years
Scandinavians have actually been using
saunas to you know detox to help after
their workouts with those sore muscles
and Joints this is an amazing way to
actually relax get yourself to sleep for
me it's post-workout how much is this I
always need it so
179.99 it's a fraction of the price of
going to any spa and it's 40 off by the
way this is one of our most popular
items okay
Houdini you're way out of there I'm
gonna I'm just gonna take a little nap
so great we partnered with all these
companies to get these deals to buy nap
sounds good so by anything you saw today
scan that QR code on your screen or head
over to CBS deals.com